hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in on duties book 1 Cicero has torquatus
the representative of the epicurean
position in philosophy argue that we
don't value or we shouldn't value the
virtues for their own sake but because
they are means to our own happiness
which consists largely in pleasure and
the absence of pain so he says that
justice basically we should get the same
treatment as all the other virtues
wisdom temperance and courage I have
shown to be so closely linked with
pleasure that they cannot possibly be
severed or sundered from it the same
must be deemed to be the case with
justice so the argument here is that
justice is not something that's valuable
for its own sake but precisely because
it leads us to a life in which we get to
enjoy the greatest amount of pleasures
and we don't have to suffer as many
pains so it's part of a well-regulated
life and there's a couple different
considerations that are being given here
one is as he says justice does not cause
any harm to a person but adds a benefit
instead and we can understand this in
terms of justice not harming other
people you know if I'm a just person I'm
not gonna take more than my fair share
if I make a contract with you I will
follow through on the contract even if I
have the opportunity to screw you over I
won't do so and so on but it can also be
understood as applying to ourselves
justice is not going to harm us and you
might say well what if by being just I
get myself in trouble or what if by
being just I put myself at a
disadvantage and torquatus doesn't
really consider those sorts of issues in
part I think because they are the way
the argument is going is that it's going
to help us by doing something for us
it's gonna do something for our
psychological state not just our
external goods he says that it provides
tranquility to the mind he uses a verb
you know trying quilok actually it makes
us tranquil and how does it do so well
partly by bringing a kind of order and
harmony into the person him or herself
but also by not leading us into desiring
all sorts of things that really are not
from an epicurean perspective good for
us in part because they lead to other
problems later on most of the things
that people would get into conflicts
about turn out to be within the realm of
what the Epicureans call neither natural
nor necessary desires or empty desires
or vain desires and he talks about that
a little bit later so by pruning those
away it provides tranquility to the mind
it also does so in another way if we
don't commit injustice we're not going
to have a bad conscience we're not going
to suffer certain fears and we're going
to talk about that when we get to
injustice interestingly he also has this
passage where he talks about hope space
hope that nothing
packing nothing will be lacking that an
uncorrupted nature desires now the
translation here has an uncorrupted
nature needs but the word is they
actually does iterance
you know so what it would in fact desire
that we can be confident that if we are
just we're not going to be deprived or
we can hope that we're not going to be
deprived of the basic things that we
want now that doesn't mean that we're
going to get everything if I want to
have a million dollars in my bank
account
which is not really a need but rather a
want that is probably not going to be
produced by being just it'll be produced
in other ways if it ever does happen
hasn't happened yet by the way I expect
you probably won't unless we have
massive inflation and you know a million
dollars is the equivalent of a thousand
dollars so those are some arguments in
favor of justice another way to look at
it is well what happens if we're unjust
and here the Epicureans from the
beginning on with Epicurus himself
placed a lot of stress on what the
effects the psychological effects of
committing injustice are so I'm gonna
jump very quickly these be these bad
forms of activity one of the big things
that Epicurus said is if you commit
injustice if you go against the laws of
the city or you go against basic rules
whatever it happens to be where you are
you can never be entirely confident that
you're wrong Act will remain undetected
so you always have to have some fear of
Revelation and they're there by
punishment or social Center because of
that you can never completely get away
from that and then interestingly
torquatus adds in there that
this is a little bit paradoxical from an
epicurean perspective even if you think
that you got away from human beings well
you still got to worry about the gods or
providence taking some sort of vengeance
upon you now why do I say that's a
little bit strange from an epicurean
perspective the Epicureans did believe
they were got there were gods and they
thought that the gods do not care at all
about human beings that's why the gods
are blessed that's why the gods enjoy
her time because they don't worry about
us that are stupid conflicts and foibles
and in Justices and they don't engage in
any sort of providential punishing but
Epicureans do recognize that people who
aren't Epicureans don't believe that
about the gods or about karma or about
fate or about whatever it happens to be
and they may in fact think that that you
know the universe is out to get them in
some way another thing that he talks
about a little bit earlier our Restless
desires when you're an unjust person
doesn't mean committing acts of
injustice alone it means that that's a
disposition within you so let's take one
particular form of that being greedy a
greedy person is not just a person who
takes more than their fair share or who
takes things that you know don't belong
to them
and belong to somebody else or does
other you know acts like that that is
part of what makes them greedy but what
makes them greedy is that that's part of
who they are it becomes part of their
character now why does a greedy person
act greedily because they have these
desires for what is more than their fair
share they have desires for other
people's things and they're posed with a
kind of you know action and an affective
dilemma a lot of the time they they know
what they're doing on some level is
wrong and yet they want to do it and so
they can be quite conflicted about this
think about people who you know engage
in petty theft for example you know they
they they may be quite bothered by it
and it can also be a sign
manifestation of some other conflict
within them that they're trying to work
out say through shoplifting or through
you know stealing random items in a
locker room or something along those
lines right
but those restless desires those make us
unhappy those fall into the
classification of what Epicureans would
call pain or trouble so to be free of
that to be just would mean not to have
to deal with all that stuff another
thing that he talks about that I think
is quite interesting hatred of one's own
fellow citizens if you're unjust sooner
or later you're going to have owed iam
of your fellow citizens within yourself
you're going to dislike people that you
don't have to dislike and that's that's
painful they're also going to dislike
you and in you know interestingly the
way this is constructed it could be
hatred that you feel directed towards
them or it could be hatred that they
feel directed towards you because they
find out that you're a greedy selfish
bastard alright or whatever other form
of injustice that we're talking about as
well so if we don't want to incur those
things then we want to be just he also
talks about rational sane uses the words
Dhanam they're healthy people value
justice they valued equity equity Oz and
they value fidelity fides which could
also be translated as a kind of honesty
keeping commitments that are are made
and here's an interesting argument that
he provides that you can break down the
world into those who have and those who
don't really have or don't have much and
they have nots the non rich non talented
people well it's stupid for them to be
unjust because they're gonna get caught
and punished and they're probably not
gonna be able to pull it off very well
so it's not very smart for them to be
unjust you know some of them are but
that's because they're they're not
thinking things through for the rich or
the talented he uses the example of
people who can speak quite well right
they also need to be
just why do they need to be just he says
the rich and clever generous conduct
seems more in keeping and liberality
wins them affection and goodwill the
surest means to a life of peace you want
other people to like you to think well
of you so that they'll leave you alone
so that they will help you out when you
need help because your house fell down
or something like that or you're you
know the economy crashed and you lost
all that money that you had you want the
goodwill of others so that you can
flourish in your own way and so what you
do if you do have resources is you
provide to other people this is where
justice becomes something like
beneficence so that when you need them
to help you they'll be there he also
goes on and he says there really is no
motive for transgressing the desires
that spring from nature are easily
gratified without doing any man wrong so
we're again we're talking about rational
sane people who restrict their desires
and pleasures to those that are easily
satisfied those that are natural to us
those of you that are imaginary ought to
be resisted for they set their
affections on nothing that is really
wanted and then he says there's more
loss and Herenton and justice itself
than there is profit in the gain that it
brings so if you are unjust you're
losing something for yourself even if
you're getting something so the the rich
the powerful the you know smart the
talented they need to be just just as
much as what Cicero probably would call
the little people do as well so again
this is the epicurean position this is
not you know all virtue ethics and this
is actually not Cicero's own point of
view this is that of the character
torquatus who is presenting it the
viewpoint is that justice is something
that we ought to have we ought to
cultivate we ought to view as a virtue
not because it's good in itself but
because in the way that it works when we
break it down it leads to a better life
for the person who is just